President Obama accidentally reveals his  daughter sasha has a Twitter account yep  it's true according to the president his  15 year old daughter sasha is an active  tweeter that's one of my great gifts  Obama revealed the news on Tuesday while  campaigning for Hillary Clinton in North  Carolina  he took a dig at Donald Trump for his  Twitter antics explaining quote  everybody can tweet but nobody actually  knows what it takes to do the job until  you've sat behind the desk  I mean Sascha tweets but she doesn't  think that she thereby should be sitting  behind the desk cue the internet freaked  out no word on any official Sasha Obama  Twitter handles but we have a pretty  good idea what she might be tweeting  about her years living at the White  House traveling abroad with her family  or maybe even that time she totally  fangirled over meeting Ryan Reynolds